مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في نشره الاخبار من
قناه الجزيره اعلن وزير العدل الامريكيه
انه اجاز اول عمليه نقل للوصول المصادره
من احد رجال النخبه الروسيه الى وزاره
الخارجيه وذلك لاستخدامها في دعم اوكرانيا
اضاف جارلاند خلال استقباله المدعي العامل
الاوكراني في واشنطن ان الاجراء ياتي
تماشيا مع السلطه الجديده التي منحها
الكونجرس لوزاره العدل
اعلنوا انني اجزت اول عمليه نقل اصول
روسيه المصادره لاستخدامها لصالح اوكرانيا
وكان صدر اعلان مني في ابريل الماضي بعد
لائحه اتهام بحق الثري الروسي النافذ
قسطنطينه بتهمه خرق العقوبات حينها اعلنت
ايضا مصادره ملايين الدولارات من حساب
مؤسسه ماليه امريكيه مصدرها عمليه التهرب
من العقوبات وامرت محكمه في نيويورك
بمصادره الاموال صالح الولايات المتحده
وبتفويض مني ستحول هذه الاموال الى
الخارجيه لتستخدم في اطار دعم الشعب
الاوكراني
من جهه قال المدعي العام لاوكراني ان
الاصول الروسيه التي سيتم نقلها ستستخدم
لصالح جهود اعاده الاعمار
نشهد اليوم التصديق على تحويل اصول مصادره
بقيمه خمسه ملايين واربع مئه الف دولار
الى وزاره الخارجيه لاستخدامها لصالح
اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا التي دمرتها الحرب
جزء مهم من المساءله يتمثل بان يدفع الطرف
المسؤول ثمن الدمار الذي تسبب به لذلك فان
التعويض عن الاضرار البشريه والماديه
الهائله التي لحقت باوكرانيا يشكل جانبا
مهما في اطار سعينا للعداله هذه رساله
واضحه ولم تكون هناك حصانه او افلات من
العقاب
وزير العمل الرومانسيه قدر قبل شهور
المبالغه بلاده التي جمدتها دول الغربيه
بحوالي نصف احتياطيات روسيا من الذهب
والعملات الاجنبيه اي حوالي ثلاثمائه
مليار دولار من جهه افادت وحده العمل
التابعته للحلفاء الغربيين المسؤولين عن
تعقب الاصول العائده للنخب الروسيه بان
الحلفاء الغربيين جمدوا 30 مليار دولار من
الاصول المملوكه للاثرياء او النخب وحوالي
300 مليار دولار للبنك المركزي الروسي
مشيره الى انه تم الحجز على عقارات مملوكه
او يسيطر عليها رعايه روس فرضت عليهم
عقوبات ومنذ اندلاع الحرب اذنت بريطانيا
تجميد اصول تزيد قيمتها عن عشرين مليار
وخمسمائه مليون دولار مملوكه
وافراد اخرين وشركات